Welcome back everyone this is going to be my loki
season 2 top 10 predictions video there's so much
stuff that they set up so many teasers and the
marvel people have been talking about how this
is all going to weed through marvel phase 4 the
movies and the other disney plus series so we'll
break it all down i will be doing videos for
marvel's what if that's going to be starting in
a couple weeks and it'll sort of build on the
craziness of all this multiverse stuff that's
happening at the end of loki season 1. If you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos i'm still doing the giveaway
for disney plus memberships all you have to do
to enter just be a subscriber and leave all
your predictions for season 2 on the video
careful for spoilers for everything that
happened during loki season 1 if you have
not seen those episodes yet but just starting
with number 10 loki season 2 will be released
between the events of doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness in ant-man 3 quantum mania both in the
marvel phase 4 timeline but also in real world
too like physically releasing episodes before they
release ant-man 3. part of the reason for that is
because doctor strange two is literally coming out
in march there's no way that they can film loki
season two and get episodes out before doctor
strange two comes and it's been widely reported
that tom hiddleston's loki is going to show up
during doctor strange 2 so that's also part of my
predictions here that i'll talk about in a second
but the whole idea is that at the end of the
finale they teased that while loki was traveling
back to the tva the timeline restarted reset so to
speak like he who remains king was talking about
another multiverse war eventually broke out in
the 31st century this same version of nathaniel
richards he who remains eventually rose up but
because the statue of kang at the tva is different
it implies that another kang won that war and
made his own timeline the dominant one isolated
it just like our version of he who remains told us
like things played out very similarly it was just
another version of kang that wound up creating the
tva and now loki doesn't know whether he's evil or
good or another manic willy wonka version of the
character like our version in part of season two
we'll be figuring that out like how is this new
kang different from the one that we just met and
will he try to stop loki from sorting this
mess out so loki kind of just got a spoiler
for the end of the next multiverse war and now
it's his job to try and sort everything out try
and fix things and restore his original timeline
some way number nine next big prediction there
will be a time jump between the end of season one
and the beginning of season two episode one just
to note that our loki has already been on this new
journey to try and sort everything out like i said
there have been reports that tom hiddleston is
going to show up as loki during doctor strange 2
they didn't say how much or exactly would he be
doing during that although i think it's kind of
implied what he's going to be doing but i think
it's implied that it would be our version of loki
that we've been following on the loki's series
this whole time in early prediction probably
pretty safe prediction he's going to try and
warn doctor strange about the multiverse war
the kang war that's coming and hopefully they'll
use it as another instance of marvel giving loki
a hulk scene it all started with iron man in
that first avengers movie we have a hulk then
in avengers infinity war they flipped it they gave
loki the lion who says it to thanos we have a hulk
and also during infinity war it was hulk who came
to warn doctor strange of the coming throughout of
thanos now it seems like it would be loki to get
that hulk type scene and he'll be the one crashing
the sanctum with a temp pad this time shouting
about someone else coming thousands of versions
of someone terrible is coming because remember
he doesn't know the name kang he just knows this
person as he who remains and technically nathaniel
richards i don't think they're actually going to
call one of the variants kang until we get to
either doctor strange 2 or ant-man 3 and probably
not till ant-man 3. like the idea is that kang
will not be the villain of doctor strange 2 it'll
be some other core doctor strange villain like
schumachorth or some other extra dimensional being
but while doctor strange 2 is going on they'll
still be the threat of this multiversal war that
plays out in the future for them but in the past
for loki because loki jumped to the end of it
basically remember the tva does not get created
till one of the kangs wins the multiversal war
and he uses the tva to ensure the sanctity of his
sacred timeline that's why we say loki got the
spoiler for the end of the war when he went back
to the tva number eight next week prediction at
the beginning of season two loki will be working
with this new version of mobius hunter b15 the
other new slightly different versions of the tva
people to try and fix what he and silvi messed up
unleashing all the kang variants and changing the
timeline so to speak but technically they didn't
change the original mcu timeline that still exists
it's just the notion that this version of king who
won the multiverse awards implied just sublimated
the original mcu timeline when he made his own
original timeline the dominant one so marvel
didn't just completely destroy the original
timeline of the marvel movies they're not going
to completely retcon everything you just watched
through avengers end game i think they'll explain
that it still exists out there as its own universe
and loki here will be fighting to save it and get
back to his version of mobius that was his friend
and eventually find sylvia again it also is part
of that number 7 at the beginning of season two
separately we'll find out what happened to sylvia
after she killed this version of he who remains
king early prediction though is that she just used
her 10 pad to flee to another apocalypse event
to hide out again but when she arrived there she
probably found the same thing that loki found at
this new version the tva everything was different
oh crap and she'll also try to clean up her mess
she created and be on her own hero arc similar to
what our loki was on during season one number six
another early prediction loki and silvi won't be
reunited again right away like they won't see each
other again until either like the cliffhanger
at the end of episode one or to a little bit
later in the season but for the most part pretty
much every character from season one is coming
back in season two but number five because most
people are probably wondering most of the major
loki variants will also probably be back in season
2 in some form or another and on top of that they
will do more funny alternate versions of loki from
the comics for instance kid loki alligator loki
both confirmed alive inside the void at the end
of episode five alligator loki was probably one of
the most popular characters on the show even tom
hiddleston was saying that he bows to alligator
loki like who is the superior loki oh clearly
alligator loki is a superior loki so he's a
pretty easy slam dunk to bring back for some funny
scenes and i'm hoping that they'll continue to
keep the jack veal kid loki around and eventually
use him when they're ready to do some full-blown
young avengers stuff in the mcu i don't know if
they plan to bring classic loki richard e grant
back because his sacrifice felt like such a great
moment for his character but they could bring him
back as another different version of loki another
older version of loki because richard e grant is
fantastic and it sounds like he had a lot of
fun doing the series you guys can let me know
in the comments which other alternate versions
of loki you want to see them use during season
two maybe because they got rid of those king loki
scenes they'll also do some more king loki during
season two but number four prediction there will
still probably only be six episodes in season two
marvel seems like they're kind of locked into that
model for the larger more expensive series either
the episodes are like 20 minutes long and they do
nine episodes or the episodes are 40 minutes plus
long and they only do six episodes hopefully
they'll find a way to either save some money
to get some extra episodes out or they'll just be
willing to spend a little bit more money and make
them eight episodes minimum but it feels like at
least for the next couple of years it'll either be
like six episodes or nine episodes or in the case
of the marvel what if series i believe there's
supposed to be 10 episodes but if you're wondering
why there are so few episodes of some of these
series like falcon and winter soldier was only
six episodes some of the upcoming marvel disney
plus series like moon night are only going to be
6 episodes it's mostly because of the amount of
money that they spend on each episode and how long
they are so the only time when they do a ton of
episodes is when the episodes themselves are very
very short but just in terms of how they pace the
episodes out during loki season 2 it'll probably
be very similar to season 1 but the advantage
going into season two is that they've already done
the work of introducing the concept of the tva
time travel variants the multiverse so they don't
have to spend all of their season two episode
one explaining that again to everyone so they
kind of have an extra episode worth of time to
spend on actual plot during season two but number
three just talking more about kang he who remains
obviously the big main villain heading into marvel
phase four now we will probably not see the same
kang the same he who remains character from season
1 again but jonathan majors will probably play
a much larger role he'll probably be in more
actual episodes as this new kang variant who's
controlling this version of the tva because this
time at least in this timeline the statue implies
that there's no mystery about the time keepers i
feel like that's what they're trying to tell us
here like this version of kang won the multiverse
war created the tva and then just told everyone
the truth i'm in charge i'm your time god do what
i say and it's part of renslayer's story because
she was heading off to find a version of kang
at the end of season one when they do a lot more
kang stuff during season 2 she'll be alongside
that version of kang it'll just be them doing
another big deep cut from the comics for their
relationship i don't know if jonathan majors would
be in every single episode but because the secret
is out so to speak about who is behind all this
who the big threat is they'll probably at least
reference him in every single episode and his
variance in this multiverse war number two they'll
also probably cover a lot of the material from the
deleted scenes that didn't make it into season
one because of timing and the virus shutdowns
primarily more backstory on renslayer in service
of establishing her relationship with kang or
a version of kang we should say more of her
relationship with mobius her backstory with him
their friendship and just more mobius backstory
in general everyone was kind of disappointed
they didn't pay off that jet ski during season
one they imply that because of the way the tva
is made up of variants that he was so obsessed
with jet skis in the 90s because that's where
the tva picked him up he's from the 90s we'll also
probably get a little more backstory from some of
the other side characters too like hunter b-15
and early prediction maybe even casey remember
casey always wincing at the side of loki like
oh god not you again stealing my juice box now
if you re-watch the ending scene from episode 6
when loki goes back and everyone's running around
going crazy if you listen really carefully you can
hear casey's voice on the intercom inside that new
version the tva claiming that he's reporting
to the armory so it sounds like this different
timeline version of casey is a full-blown
hunter like a more badass version of casey
just as a funny twist on the meek version
from season one who didn't know what fish were
in number one really big early prediction here
if they do get all the loki season 2 episodes out
before ant-man 3 quantum mania they will not end
the season with loki and sylvia mobius defeating
kang and fixing the multiverse war like season
2 will not end with them completely unscrewing
their mess things will still be in utter chaos in
regardless of whether or not ant-man 3 comes out
before or after loki season 2 also during that
movie they probably will not completely defeat
all the kang variants like it's implied that
a version of kang during that movie will be
a different version like the true version of kang
who fought the avengers in all the classic comics
but there's supposed to be infinite versions
of him coming making him the next thanos level
avengers threat in marvel phase 4. so early
theory too both the ant-man characters in
that movie and the loki characters on the loki
series will handle some of the versions of kang
but they won't completely defeat the threat of the
infinite kang to make a rick and morty reference
the infinite rick the idea that there are infinite
versions out there till we get to avengers 5 in a
sort of secret war style multiverse movie because
that's kind of the promise of this multiverse war
that they just tease that will actually see that
play out in a big movie but paying off more secret
war stuff during avengers 5 sounds like it'll
be marvel's way of sort of holding off on doing
major galactus stuff till even later because
i think we all expect marvel to use galactus
as another future thanos level big bad but before
loki started getting into all this multiversal war
stuff i would have said that they would have
waited till avengers 6 to do a secret war
storyline but now it seems like they're implying
they're going to roll really hard on that way
faster than everyone expected so let me know
in the comments do you think that loki season 2
and ant-man 3 quantum mania will help them build
up to an avengers 5 secret wars style movie
there's a big kang video that i'm still working
on i'll post that tomorrow and my marvel what if
episodes are going to start in a couple weeks so
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of those and i'll name a
giveaway winner when i post my next marvel video
everyone click here to learn about the loki
finale alternate ending alternate post credit
scenes and more deleted scenes and click
here for my full loki episode 6 finale video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!